it was an amazing moment in the Oval
Office today when pop-culture icon
rapper extraordinaire Kanye West met
with President Trump before the cameras
he unleashed a 10-minute monologue where
he tried to explain his love of all
things energy in my home Superman
[Music]
sometimes unlikely figures emerge in
American history to play important roles
illuminating at times important truths
and today Kanye West in his own
eccentric way exposed the intolerance of
the left there denunciations of his
White House appearance were immediate
and withering when it comes to issues of
Kanye West bringing black people to
president Trump that is that's a
misnomer it certainly doesn't speak to
the diversity and sort of broad
experiences of 40 million of black
people well this is a reality TV show
who we were watching I mean there was a
because that was an assault on our White
House an assault on our white house well
Kanye did use some coarse language they
shouldn't have used but in other
settings liberals would have called that
authentic he was being his true self
speaking his own truth but if you want
to talk about assaults or impropriety
and will in the White House how about
this or this
Kanye West is hardly a political
philosopher and I've always believed
that entertainers should first entertain
and keep their politics separate from
their art but I cannot remember any
artists on the Left who was treated with
the same vitriol and hatred as Kanye
West's
objected to since he announced his
support for the president when Katy
Perry or Miley Cyrus were headlining
Hillary Clinton rallies running through
dorms to register voters I don't
remember anyone at MSNBC or CNN
criticizing them for lacking policy
experience how about when Hillary
Clinton sat down for an interview with
that probing policy maven mary j blige
it ain't no secret no secret my friend
you can get kill just living in your
American skin
Oh like an old coffee commercial from
the 70s remember Obama was the biggest
celebrity hound of them all
I mean his relationship was mutual to
celebrities he was kind of a celebrity
and they loved him as vice versa
here's Barack and Michelle serenading uh
sure in the White House but no
impropriety or assault on the White
House then and how about Beyonce and
jay-z they were in and out of the Obama
White House more frequently than the
Secret Service that was all perfectly
acceptable no policy concerns then but
when it was announced two days back that
Kanye would be holding a meeting with
Trump at the White House all hell broke
loose
so Kanye's gonna let the president use
him again
he's the token negro of the of the Trump
administration Kanye West is what
happens when Negroes don't read black
folks are about to you know trade Kanye
West and the racial draft okay Kanye is
being subjected to the attacks that
awake any black conservative who dares
to break ranks with the Democratic
monolith liberals kind of treat these
entertainers like pawns who are not
allowed to deviate from the leftist
group think at all
god protect any Hispanic gay or black
who breaks ranks and goes their own way
politically remember the scorn that
singer Harry Belafonte and the civil
rights activist Harry Belafonte heaped
on Condoleezza Rice and : Powell for
working for George Bush probably the
rice go to power through the bush
because they believe as he does they
embrace his ideology they embrace his
imperial appetite
Lackey's and tools of that and my
reference to them has a failed house
ladies they were not the masters of
their own destiny they had the choice to
house slaves that was really nice more
than 30 years ago a prominent figure in
the Reagan administration argued that
blacks should cast off liberalism for
conservative solutions and summed up how
the GOP had lost so much ground saying
Democrats smugly assumed blacks are
monolithic and will by force of
circumstances always huddle to the left
of the political spectrum the political
right watches this herd mentality in
action concedes that blacks are
monolithic picks up a few dissidents and
wistfully shrugs at the seemingly
unbreakable hold of the liberal left on
black Americans that officials name was
Clarence Thomas then chair of the Equal
Opportunity Commission individuals such
as the brilliant conservative economist
Tom Sol were courageous because as
Thomas noted they refused to give in to
the cult mentality and childish
obedience that hypnotized black
Americans into mindless political trance
this is Justice Thomas in 2007 we're
here not to be proselytized but to think
for ourselves and at bottom isn't that
why we one of the reasons we love a free
society that we get to think for
ourselves make our decisions based on
certain principles and to make it
possible for others to do the same
absolutely now I'm not gonna say the
rapper Kanye West's Tom soul or Clarence
Thomas of course he's not but I will say
that unless he's doing a giant punking
of America he has guts and gusto just
because he dares to think for himself
think differently and his outspoken
over-the-top manner
he's pilloried by the politically
correct performers and politics and
journalism and of course in the
entertainment industry he represents a
danger
to the left because of its huge cultural
influence and moments like this are
absolutely intolerable in frightening to
liberals I don't want to take I don't
want to put you in that spot not
standing in that spot I love this guy
right here let me get this guy
[Music]
could it be that the Trump West Show was
an indication that the old Democrats
monopoly on black voters is in jeopardy
there is more reasons for the Liberals
to be concerned the president's support
among African Americans is nearly double
that of last year and the latest
Rasmussen poll President Trump now has a
36 approval rating among African
Americans some attributed the rise to
the support from Kanye West and of
course a historic low unemployment rate
in the black community
what other the cause whatever the reason
the shifting support
among African Americans is very very
significant Democrats cannot win a
national election without their huge
swath of black voters and perhaps Kanye
is giving them a reason to look
elsewhere for political answers so next
time you hear liberal pundits writing
him off as a crazy slave denying lunatic
remember it's all about the numbers they
have to smear West for fear that black
Americans will follow him into the arms
of President Donald Trump and what are
the Democrats going to do then and
that's the angle